[Music]
a few
episodes ago i don't know maybe 20 or
30.
it's talking about these stories we tell
ourselves
right these things that we happen that
we carry around with us like bricks in
our backpack
and i offered folks this
write these things down what are the
stories you tell yourself
write them down demand evidence from
these things and then put
them down and put them down means
different things for different people
some people write letters and they burn
them some people i had a client once
that
wrote letters and they shot it up with
one of his ppu guns or whatever
but i offered people hey send them to me
just put them in the mail and be
done with it have a spiritual moment
have a
existential putting these stuff in the
mail write them down and
let them go and i got letters man and
hey the offer still stands
you got something that you cannot get
out of your soul
that you wake up anxious you go to bed
and your heart's racing you wake up at 2
a.m
and you're thinking about this thing
that happened thinking about things that
you did the things that you
said that you can't go back and change
there were 10 years ago 20 years ago
five years ago
the things that happened to you the
things that happened to somebody you
love
at some point you have to make the
decision i'm not going to be defined by
the worst thing that ever happened to me
i'm not going to be defined by the worst
thing i ever did
and i've got to decide i want to be a
part of a healing process
this one take a different road and that
starts with taking the bricks out of
your backpack and setting them down
you're welcome to mail them to me use a
pen
on a piece of paper and write them down
and mail them so i got letters man
and some of these were gut wrenching and
hard
and beautiful i just picked two this
morning
um there's i mean the number like this
here's one and and these are heavy i
want you just to know that they're heavy
um some of these had no names on them no
return addresses on them they just came
to me at work i didn't know where they
were from
that sometimes they had a postmark city
but sometimes you know i don't know
if they're actually mailing if they're
on vacation or whatever but here's one i
got
um close your eyes and listen to this
letter
my name is xyz and i'm a huge fan of
your show
your positivity and compassion is
infectious makes my day better hope it's
making
me better thanks man i heard on your
show that you told someone to send you a
letter with the word
cheater on it as a way of letting that
go and i was planning on doing something
similar about burning it and i figured
i'd just send it your way
so here's my situation and this person
actually sent two letters one to me and
one to the
person that hurt them
so here's my situation and what the
other letter will be
tomorrow i'll be asking the parents of
the most wonderful
sweet tough bubbly and lovely girl for
their blessing to marry their daughter
there is one chapter of her past i still
haven't gotten over and will hopefully
finish in premarital counseling
in her previous relationship she was
pushed on her physical boundaries and
was raped
she's processed it forgiven the guy that
hasn't even asked for forgiveness
and considers it part of a plan she's
thankful for chances she gets to use it
as a way to connect and help others
she's moved completely past it but i
still hold resentment towards this guy
uh-huh i don't want him to occupy my
thoughts or energy anymore so attached
is my letter to him
i hope you get this and maybe speak
about being in relationships with people
who've had an abusive past
and he goes on to write a letter to that
guy
the fortitude to be able to look in the
mirror and say
i'm letting somebody that i've never met
but that it hurt the woman i'm gonna
spend the rest of my life with
and i gotta let that go
because all i'm gonna do hanging on to
that is i'm just gonna
drown the current relationship i'm in
and the letter that he wrote is
as gut-wrenching and heartbreaking as
you can imagine but it's powerful
and so if you're listening to the show
and that's your letter i want to tell
you thank you as an honor that you sent
that to me you trusted me with that
i think you're a brave stud
for saying hey i'm putting this down and
i'll tell you this is gonna be a healing
process
you say my wife's over it this will
circle back and there'll be some
challenges but she's got a
rock star by her side who understands
hey
you were hurt somebody somebody
took a lot from you and i love you
and we're gonna be in this together
moving forward
thanks for sending that man and thanks
for being strong enough to say i'm gonna
set this down
another letter we got um no name
man just says in giant
marker no more second guessing
and underneath it in pen it writes i
don't need to second guess
every decision i've made
it is what it is he left me here and
when he did he left
all the joy and happiness and
opportunity
to be healed he left us with a quiet
joyous peaceful home he left me with a
safe
calm place to raise mine our children
where they don't wait for the next shoe
to drop
i couldn't make him stop yelling make
him happy enough
i couldn't make him be here long enough
to just enjoy our beautiful lives
together there are things i miss
and i'd never imagined for this for
myself or my family
but when i step back and really look at
what he gave us by finding himself a
better life
i have no doubt in my mind i'm doing the
best i can
that i gave everything i had to that
21-year marriage
and i loved him and i loved our kids
i'm still trying to prove myself i'm
still trying to
show i can run a household and pay the
mortgage and all the bills and provide a
wonderful environment for myself
and my kids all without any support from
him
he never even asks if they need anything
but that's the way it is
i know this and i don't fight it
i just continually readjust the sails of
my boat
pointing towards my north star
no more second guessing
21 years he just looked at her and said
i'm out
good luck with kids
man that's hard hard hard
and yet she says i'm learning how to do
this and it's a grind and it's tough
and it's painful and i second-guess
myself but i'm putting it down
i can't go back and change him can't go
back and change those 21 years i can't
go back and edit the past but i can
write a new tomorrow
i don't know who sent it i don't know
where it's from but i want to tell you
if you're listening
what an honor you're a strong
powerful extraordinary woman
find a community that will rally around
you
let people support you so you can get
some sleep and some rest
and your kids are lucky to have you
awesome
hey send me your letters that stuff
you're carrying around those stories you
tell yourself those stories you were
told
growing up those stories you're told at
work still
write them in a letter put them in the
mailbox set them down
be done with it thank y'all for being
brave